and you do Blade Runner I need your
magic so we've got a new proper trailer
for Blade Runner 20 49 I've talked a
little bit about this film before and I
want to now talk about my thoughts on
this trailer before I get into them sort
of too deeply or too specifically I'm
going to say my general overall feelings
are mixed and I have points of concern
now I want I just want to stress that my
concern about this is not of a level
like the kind of concern that I had when
I started seeing trailers for ghost in
the shell which was bringing all kinds
of alarm bells and got worse with
everything this case I'm still fairly
covenants going to be a good movie I so
as I lay out my concerns it's more about
it not being what I would like to see
out of the Blade Runner movie so
understand nothing that I'm about to say
leads to a conclusion therefore I think
the movie will be bad not going there
however it does still seem to be at
least as the marketing is delivering it
headed in a direction that is not quite
what I want but let's let's start I
always like to start positive before I
just bump every buddy out so it looks
great I mean that's that's not a shock
Denis Villeneuve who I just butchered
the proper pronunciation that name but
he got me he makes really good looking
movies and it looks very much like Blade
Runner and it looked it looks like
something really scoured a genre they've
got also makes gorgeous movies so it
looks great a little bits of soundtrack
that we get sounds like Blade Runner
that's big for me I love that soundtrack
so that's a big deal for me so that
stuff is all good so when I say things
seem a little bit often are quite
clicking for me it's in the fine details
and if things just being a little bit
off now I will cop to the possibility as
I usually do that it may be this trailer
is not properly representative of the
film
the things that I'm worried about are
not actually the case in the finished
product I am aware that is possible I am
open to that as a possibility and as I
said unlike say the trailers for goes to
the shell which made me actively decide
to not even go and see the movie that is
not the case here I am still fully
United you see this movie and nothing
that I'm about to talk about is making
me go ah so there's just a feel and
there's just a vibe but I think it
started with Jared Leto speaking and his
lines about how civilization is built on
a disposable workforce and there was
something about his delivery combat that
just felt very art it felt there it felt
villain monologue II now if I were to
contrast that would say Eldon Tyrell in
the original you know who obviously has
kind of the same understanding I mean
he's literally building a disposable
workforce but he seemed to have some
degree of awareness and some degree of
having come to terms with but still
understanding that there are issues with
what he does you know he he met he
didn't revel in the fact that what he
was building was going to die and he
even seemed to have a certain
understanding that what he was putting
through was putting these creatures
these beings he was creating what he put
them through was probably not fair there
was a certain almost apologetic miss you
know when he was talking to Roy about
the fact that he couldn't give him
longer life or you know what he's
talking to Deckard and he says how you
know they give them false memories to
create a cushion for their emotions it
you know he says it so they they control
them better but there's a certain just
little touch of almost affection in his
voice you get the sense that he almost
kind of wants to give the replicants the
best very deliberately and forcibly
short existence that he can afford them
so that kind of shade of gray that
softness that you know I can't get a
total read on this guy on one line
reading is gone I feel like I get a
we followed line I get a really solid
character reading on Jared Leto's like
right off the bat I was there
there's our villain right there you
don't get that front row and then not
very much has to do with Blade Runner
being a noir and in two hours you don't
deal in absolutes you don't deal in you
know firm this is the way it is which is
the other thing there was a whole
extended no biggie we're hearing you
know about it there's a wall and then
you removed wall there's war it's like
you're talking in a lot of certainty for
a story set in the world that doesn't
deal in certainty and you're talking
about big you know we are the last line
of defense and yeah I'm those weren't
the exact words but it that sort of
feels like that's too big that's too big
for Blade Runner what I really love
about blade runner's the world that it
is said it is huge and some of the ideas
that it kind of skirts up against are
really big ideas but the actual plot the
story the characters are not overly
embroiled in this Deckard isn't trying
to unravel these philosophical
conundrums or some maxim crunch in the
tyrell cobra he's just trying to do this
one case he was assigned to and he's
skirting up against he's brushing
against these much bigger things but
they don't eat they don't consume what
he's actually doing he still focused on
little thing because that's that's what
you therefore that's what he knows he
can handle he has a sense can you
probably notice he's not up for these
bigger things that he's skirting by I
mean you know it's the same it's like
Chinatown forget it Jake is China's I'm
like that's too big you were dealing
with this little thing it brought you to
this bigger thing you can't handle that
and that's that is the feel of new are
and that is the feel of Blade Runner so
when characters are talking in these big
art sweeping kind of dialogues I worry
that that the film is is over expanding
the scope because I don't think Blade
Runner needs its scope expanded because
there's something wonderful about a
really fully fleshed out huge feeling
world but a small story being told with
that that and that's one of the many
things I love about Blade Runner and
again based solely off this marketing
I'm a little bit worried that we're not
going to get that now you know I do have
a certain amount of faith in this
director I think he has the potential to
be able to handle this nobody zoom but
again I'm gonna go off the marketing
that they've shown me in the marketing
that they've shown me makes me just a
little bit lit and I kind of had to
reverse engineer this whole feeling
because after watching the trailer I was
kinda like something feels off and I
really had to kind of pick at it to
figure out what was causing this gut
feeling that wasn't quite selling it now
there are Moe's yellows the moment I
really liked and this might sound weird
or maybe other people felt the same way
I don't know let's find out
the moment that I was like yeah was
actually between Harrison Ford and Ryan
Gosling when Harrison Ford's is what if
you want and there's a pause and Ryan
Gosling just says I just want to ask you
some questions and that feels right
that's new are that's like look I'm just
here to ask you this quite these
questions and you know you're looking at
this this crazy setting with this mood
lighting you know it obviously went
through a lot together I was like I just
want to ask you some questions and that
that moment that like connection between
the two of them looking at each other
that that that felt like Blade Runner in
a way that you know Jared Leto with his
milky eyes giving what really does feel
like like a chunk of a villain monologue
that that's that feels off and you know
like I said then I'm not going I'm not
going to see this movie I still
definitely plan to see this movie I have
a pretty good amount of faith in this
director in like I said visually and
they've got the soundtrack and I'm I'm
still hopeful and nothing that I see
here makes me go oh they got it all
wrong it just seems to be pointing in a
direction that isn't what I want now
that's not to say that it's not going
because it's not to say you shouldn't
enjoy it maybe what other people like
about Blade Runner isn't what I like
about Blade Runner but for the things
that I love about that film I I'm
worried that they're going to get lost
because you know the sense that
characters are actually quite small is a
big part of that original film you know
that kind of writer had his whole thing
his whole I've seen things you people
wouldn't believe moment before his death
it's very much rooted in the idea of
these these characters are so small in
this insane gorgeous world that we've
been watching them you'll move around
within and bump up against big ideas but
like they're they're still their tiny
little things in all of this and I just
I they're nothing in the trailer make me
think this is going to happen but God
help us if there's any kind of huge
corporate level big conspiracy if that's
the plot we're in a lot of trouble
because that it needs to be focused on
people and well people and recompense it
needs to be focus on individual
characters not this should not blow up
into oh my god we just blew the lid up
no no no no blowing lids keep it on the
characters that's what that's what I
want out of Blade Runner and things
about this trailer make me worried that
they might lose that tighter focus and I
hope that they don't and as I say most
of the time when I express concerns I
want to be wrong I actually I love being
wrong I love thinking that I know why
something more worth going in and
getting something like that works and
it's fun and I love it that's one of my
favorite things so I want to be wrong
please go ahead and tell me everyone
politely if you would so it can in any
case what were your thoughts on this
trailer for Blade Runner 20 49 whatever
they were drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it don't
forget to like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at councils of geese give a
listen to the council of geeks podcast
or and/or the punch like a girl podcasts
both available on iTunes and stitcher
they are on separate feeds though and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]